>> Dana: SORRY.
DAVID LEE, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET’S BRING IN ACTING HOMELAND
SECURITY SECRETARY CHAD WOLF IN
JUST A QUICK NOTE, I CAN HEAR
THE CONTROL ROOM, IF YOU COULD
MUTE MY MIC THERE.
SECRETARY WELCOME I THINK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US TODAY.
THERE’S A LOT THAT’S HAD TO
HAPPEN IN ORDER TO GET ALL OF
THIS PROTECTIVE GEAR CALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY TO ALL OF THESE
HOSPITALS AND THEY’RE SAYING
THEY DON’T HAVE ENOUGH.
COULD YOU TELL ME WHERE YOU
THINK YOU ARE IN TERMS OF TRYING
TO MEET THAT DEMAND?
>> ABSOLUTELY, AND THANKS FOR
HAVING ME ON THIS AFTERNOON.
SO FEMA ALONG WITH DOD PERSONNEL
ARE REALLY ENERGIZING THE SUPPLY
CHAIN AND WE TALKED ABOUT AN AIR
BRIDGE, THOSE ARE FLIGHTS FROM
ASIA WORKING WITH THOSE MEDICAL
MANUFACTURERS MAKING SURE THAT
THAT INFORMATION -- THOUGH
SUPPLIES GET TO THE U.S. IN A
MATTER OF HOURS VERSUS 30 TO 37
DAYS WHEN THEY WOULD NORMALLY
COME ON A MARITIME CARGO SHIP SO
WE ARE TRYING TO ENERGIZE THE
EXISTING SUPPLY CHAIN ROUTING
PPE EQUIPMENT THE HOT SPOTS
AROUND THE COUNTRY AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT
AND WE ARE ENERGIZING THAT
SUPPLY CHAIN SO THAT OTHER
MEDICAL DISTRIBUTORS CAN
CONTINUE TO FLOW THAT
INFORMATION TO THOSE HOSPITALS,
TO THOSE NURSING HOMES, AND
OTHER AREAS THAT THEY NORMALLY
SEND THEIR PPE AND THOSE
SUPPLIES TOO.
SO WE ARE TRYING TO CONFRONT
THIS A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT WAYS
AND RIGHT NOW, IT’S WORKING.
WE ARE FLYING IN 19 FLIGHTS FROM
ASIA, ANOTHER 52 PLANNED, SO WE
ARE REALLY TRYING TO PUSH AS
MUCH PPE INTO THE SYSTEM AS
POSSIBLE.
>> Dana: I WAS THINKING ABOUT
THE ROLE THAT FEMA HAS PLAYED IN
TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE IN ALL
SORTS OF DIFFERENT THINGS
INCLUDING WHEN I WAS THERE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE, THERE WAS
OBVIOUSLY SEVERAL OF THEM.
THOSE ARE OFTEN LOCALIZED
EVENTS, SO MAYBE FEMA HELPS A
FOUR STATE AREA BUT THIS IS A
NATIONAL CRISIS, AND I WONDER
WHETHER YOU HAVE FOUND WHAT THE
PRESSURE POINTS ARE ON FEMA AND
MAYBE WHAT ELSE HE MIGHT NEED
FROM CONGRESS IN ORDER TO HELP
TRY TO GET THAT DONE.
>> YOU’RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
FEMA IS USED TO RESPONDING TO
BOTH NATURAL AND MAN-MADE
DISASTERS BUT AS YOU INDICATED,
USUALLY VERY LOCALIZED SO HERE
WE HAVE ALL 50 STATES, ALL
TERRITORIES THAT ARE AT A
CATEGORY FIVE OR A CATEGORY FOUR
HURRICANE IN MOST INSTANCES ON
THE TYPE OF LEVEL AND SUPPORT
THAT THEY NEED.
SO IT REALLY IS AN UNPRECEDENTED
SITUATION THAT FEMA IS
CONFRONTING.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT SUPPLIES FOR
THE SUPPLY CHAIN, THAT IS A
PRIVATE SECTOR INDUSTRY.
SO FEMA WORKING THROUGH DOD HAS
REALLY GONE ABOVE AND BEYOND
REALLY TRYING TO GET A HANDLE
AND AN INSIGHT OF HOW THAT
INFORMATION FLOWS IN THAT
PRIVATE SUPPLY CHAIN NETWORK SO
THEY CAN TRACK THOSE MATERIALS
TO THOSE HOT SPOTS AND REDIRECT
THEM.
OF COURSE AS YOU MENTIONED, WE
CONTINUE TO GET SUPPORT FROM
CONGRESS.
THE FUNDING THAT THEY PROVIDED
NOT ONLY FEMA BUT OTHER ELEMENTS
OF THE DEPARTMENT AND THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT IS HELPING IN THIS
FIGHT.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO EVALUATE THE
RESOURCES THAT WE NEED, BUT WE
ARE PUTTING TO USE THE RESOURCES
THEY’VE GIVEN US THUS FAR AND
WILL CONTINUE TO PUSH TESTING,
SUPPLIES, PPE TO THOSE HOT SPOT
AREAS AND CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THOSE OTHER AREAS AS YOU
MENTIONED AT THE TOP OF YOUR
SHOW.
DETROIT, MICHIGAN, OTHER AREAS
THAT WE WANT TO ADDRESS BEFORE
THEY BECOME A HOT SPOT.
>> I WONDER, WHEN HE WOKE UP
THIS MORNING ON YOUR TO-DO LIST
OR THE THING YOU ARE MOST
WORRIED ABOUT, WHAT WAS THAT?
>> FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY PERSPECTIVE,
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE EYE IS ON
THE BALL REGARDING COVID AND
RESPONDING TO THIS.
I AM ALWAYS VERY CONCERNED THAT
WE MAKE SURE TO DO OUR
TRADITIONAL COUNTERTERRORISM
MISSION THAT THE DEPARTMENT.
OUR ADVERSARIES WHETHER IT’S
FROM A CYBER PERSPECTIVE OR JUST
THE NATION STATE PERSPECTIVE ARE
STILL HARD AT WORK, SO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE OUR CAPABILITIES ARE
NOT DEGRADED AND WE ARE NOT
MISSING THE LARGER PICTURE AS WE
RESPOND TO COVID.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF ENTITIES
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT RESPONDING
RESPONDING, A LOT OF FOLKS DOING
A LOT OF GOOD WORK, BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
ADVERSARIES AREN’T TRYING TO
TEST THAT.
>> Dana: ONE LAST THING,
YOU’RE ALSO TRYING TO ALERT
THINGS THAT THERE ARE ATTEMPTS
TO DEFRAUD PEOPLE THAT ARE OUT
THERE.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY TO
AMERICANS THAT ARE TURNING TUNIN
TODAY WHAT THEY SHOULD BE AWARE
OF?
>> I THINK WHAT WE’VE SEEN IS
ANY CRISIS, THERE ARE BAD ACTORS
OUT THERE THAT WILL TRY TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF INDIVIDUALS.
SO FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE,
EXPORTS AND IMPORTS, FAKE OR
FRAUDULENT PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
TRYING TO COME IN AND GO OUT OF
THE COUNTRY, CERTAINLY
IDENTIFYING THAT USING THAT FROM
AN ICE PERSPECTIVE.
HOMELAND SECURITY WHO WERE ALSO
TRYING TO PLAY ON THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
CYBER, INTERNET SCAMS, WE SEE
BAD PEOPLE TRYING TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
HERE, SO I GUESS FOR YOUR
VIEWERS OUT THERE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
IS ON IT, DOING OUR JOB EVERY
DAY IN CONJUNCTION TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE IDENTIFY, WE
INVESTIGATE, WE DISRUPT THESE
ATTEMPTS TO EITHER DEFRAUD THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND WORST CASE
IS PROVIDE EQUIPMENT THAT IS
VERY DANGEROUS.
>> Dana: ABSOLUTELY.